"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-David Diop, les écrivains
racontent-il mieux l'Afrique ?
-Alors...
L'Afrique peut être racontée par
tous ceux qui y vivent, je pense,
pas simplement
les écrivains.
Et... et puis,
la raconter à qui ?
Ca aussi,
c'est une question.
Peut-être que moi
je raconte l'Afrique
à des gens
qui n'y ont jamais été,
mais c'est pas toute l'Afrique,
c'est mon Afrique à moi.
-Votre Afrique à vous.
-Et chacun a une expérience
vraiment personnelle de l'Afrique.
Moi, elle est liée
à mon enfance, à mon père, ma mère.
-On va y revenir.
Vous êtes franco-sénégalais.
-Voilà.
Et puis est liée
aussi à une époque,
parce que ma jeunesse
que j'y ai passé,
eh bien, elle s'éloigne.
-Vous avez fait toutes vos études
là-bas ? Les premières études,
l'école primaire...
-Oui, l'école primaire,
le collège, le lycée.
Oui, oui.
-N'y a-t-il pas justement
un paradoxe aujourd'hui,
parce qu'on dit que l'Afrique,
c'est le continent de l'oralité,
le Sénégal singulièrement,
le pays des griots,
et il y a de plus en plus
d'écrivains qui racontent
l'Afrique justement, pas uniquement
au Sénégal, mais partout ?
Il y a une foison d'écrivains
aujourd'hui.
-Oui, oui. Dans chaque pays.
Après, l'Afrique est très grande.
Mais dans chaque pays africain,
il y a des écrivains
qui écrivent l'Afrique,
qui la racontent comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure,
mais contrairement
à ce qu'on pense,
l'écrit, en tout cas
en Afrique de l'Ouest,
existe depuis très longtemps.
On a retrouvé des textes
et des manuscrits.
-De Tombouctou notamment.
-Oui.
-Au Mali.
Et on sait
qu'au Sénégal par exemple
il y avait des transcriptions
du wolof mais avec l'alphabet arabe.
-Le wolof, c'est la langue
la plus usitée en Afrique
au Sénégal.
-Au Sénégal, oui,
c'est une langue vernaculaire.
Et donc l'écrit est
fort ancien en Afrique.
Après, la pratique
de la littérature, de l'écriture,
elle est arrivée
sous la forme écrite évidemment
au moment
de la colonisation.
Mais je sais, mon père
me le racontait, qu'il y avait
des joutes de poètes
et des improvisations
poétiques
qui ne relevaient pas
simplement du griotisme,
qui n'appartenaient
pas simplement aux griots,
et il y avait un goût pour la langue
et la littérature, la poésie,
qui existait avant l'écriture,
à côté de l'écriture.
Et ensuite, les formes prises
par le roman par exemple
le roman, c'est une façon
de raconter une histoire
qui appartient à l'Occident.
Eh bien, cette forme-là
a été introduite
au moment
de la colonisation.
-Et aujourd'hui, il y a
des écrivains
qui écrivent exclusivement
en langue vernaculaire,
en wolof au Sénégal ?
-Alors, pas exclusivement.
J'ai en tête un écrivain
qui s'appelle Boubacar Boris Diop,
qui est...
-Votre homonyme.
-On partage le même nom,
mais on n'est pas de la même
famille. Et lui s'illustre
par cette possibilité
qu'il s'est donné à lui-même
d'écrire en français,
c'est un très bon écrivain
en français,
et d'écrire également en wolof.
Et il traduit lui-même
ses livres,
parfois ses romans,
du français en wolof.
-La forme romanesque,
c'est le colon qui l'a apportée.
C'est une forme,
je dirais, occidentale
d'une certaine façon. Vous,
c'est votre principale
façon de raconter
et vous racontez en français.
Vous êtes en langue française.
Est-ce que c'est votre univers,
la francophonie ?
-Alors, déjà...
-Vous vous en revendiquez
ou, au contraire,
est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous voulez arranger
à votre façon ?
-En fait, la francophonie,
c'est une institution. Ma langue
maternelle est le français,
ma mère est française
ce que je fais
avec le français,
c'est que j'en fais
ma langue d'écrivain.
Et comme j'ai deux sensibilités
culturelles,
eh bien, je travaille le français
pour y faire entrer
un autre horizon culturel.
Et donc c'est un travail
sur la langue.
C'est un travail finalement
d'enrichissement du français
par un contexte,
des univers culturels,
qui sont très différents
de l'univers culturel
des Français de métropole.
Et ça, je l'appelle pas
la francophonie.
Pour moi,
c'est naturel en fait.
C'est ma langue d'écrivain.
Il y a un écrivain
que vous connaissez, qui s'appelle
Ahmadou Kourouma, et pour moi...
-Qui est ivoirien,
lui.
-Lui est ivoirien.
Et c'est un
des premiers écrivains
d'expression française
qui s'est approprié
le français.
C'est-à-dire que
dans les années 60, 70,
il a vu son premier manuscrit refusé
parce qu'on considérait que,
d'un point de vue académique,
sa langue française,
sa langue d'écrivain
n'était pas correcte.
Il a adapté le français,
il en a fait sa langue d'écrivain,
pour faire rentrer son univers
culturel dans cette langue.
C'est le premier,
à la différence des anglophones,
qui sont beaucoup plus libéraux
de ce point de vue,
c'est le premier à avoir travaillé
la langue française
sans avoir peur d'être pris pour
quelqu'un qui ne la maîtrisait pas.
-Kourouma, c'est un
des plus grands écrivains africains,
d'origine ivoirienne,
qui a écrit
notamment "Allah n'est pas obligé",
un livre qui a eu...
-"Les soleils des indépendances".
-Vous, vous êtes originaire
d'un pays où il y avait
une figure tutélaire
des lettres, Léopold Sédar Senghor,
et dans un livre qui a eu
le prix Goncourt, vous, vous avez eu
le prix Goncourt des Lycéens,
mais qui a eu le prix récemment,
c'est Mohamed Mbougar Sarr.
Mohamed Mbougar Sarr parle
de Senghor en disant
que c'est un héritage encombrant.
Est-ce que c'est
votre opinion aussi ?
-Euh...
Alors, non.
C'est pas du tout...
-On voit Mohamed Mbougar Sarr.
-Ah oui, Mohamed.
-Qui est un jeune
et brillant écrivain.
-Oui, et un excellent écrivain.
La figure tutélaire,
vous avez dit...
-Senghor.
-De Senghor.
Non, elle n'est pas
encombrante pour moi,
c'est-à-dire que,
comme toute littérature,
il y a histoire
qu'on peut faire commencer
avant Senghor
et évidemment prolonger après lui.
Mais c'est quand même
un écrivain, un poète,
qui est extrêmement profond
et qui a travaillé lui aussi
à faire de la langue française
une langue africaine.
-Je disais en introduction
que vos livres sont
des livres qui se promènent
dans l'histoire de l'Afrique,
dans l'histoire de votre pays,
du Sénégal et il y a
un président de la République,
il y a une quinzaine d'années,
qui a dit que, justement, l'Afrique
n'était pas rentrée dans l'histoire.
C'est Nicolas Sarkozy,
c'était un discours qu'il a prononcé
en 2007 à Dakar.
Vous avez été heurté
par ce discours ?
Qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé ?
-Alors, je suis enseignant
de littérature du 18e siècle
à l'université de Pau.
Et je travaille
sur des récits de voyage
qui ont été écrits par des voyageurs
du 17e ou 18e siècle
français, mais européens,
et c'était une époque où, en effet,
on disait que l'histoire
n'avait pas d'Afrique.
Et donc, quand j'ai entendu
ce discours,
j'ai cru entendre des choses
dites il y a très longtemps
et sur lesquelles...
-En fait, Nicolas Sarkozy
ne fait que répéter ce qui se disait
de la part des explorateurs ou...
-Il a été inspiré peut-être
par son conseiller de l'époque.
-Henri Guaino.
-Oui. Mais alors, de quelle histoire
parle-t-on aussi ?
Entrer dans l'histoire.
L'Afrique a une histoire millénaire.
Et donc je trouvais
que c'était extrêmement maladroit.
D'ailleurs, à l'université
Cheikh Anta Diop,
des universitaires
qui assistaient à ce discours,
ayant entendu ces phrases, se sont
levés et ont quitté la salle.
-Vous avez eu, je le disais,
le prix Goncourt
des Lycéens, c'était en 2018,
avec un livre qui a un titre
magnifique. Vous avez le don
des titres d'ailleurs,
"Frère d'âme".
C'est une plongée dans l'univers
des tirailleurs sénégalais.
Ce que je crois savoir, c'est que,
en fait, c'est pas la rencontre
de tirailleurs sénégalais qui vous a
inspiré ce livre. Pas du tout.
C'est votre arrière-grand-père
maternel
qui lui est landais
et qui avait fait la guerre
de 14-18.
-Oui, oui.
Alors, je l'ai pas
compris immédiatement,
c'est-à-dire qu'après la parution
de "Frère d'âme",
j'ai eu à répondre
à des interviews comme aujourd'hui
et petit à petit, je me suis
rendu compte qu'il fallait
que je réfléchisse
sur les raisons pour lesquelles
j'avais choisi d'écrire un livre
mettant en scène un combattant
de la Première Guerre mondiale.
Et je me suis rappelé
que ma mère disait
que mon arrière-grand-père,
donc qui était landais,
eh bien, était parti à la guerre
et était revenu, avait été
blessé assez gravement,
parce qu'il a été gazé à l'ypérite
et n'avait jamais rien dit
sur ce qu'il avait vécu.
Et je pense que je me suis intéressé
à cette Première Guerre mondiale
grâce ou à cause de lui.
Et quand j'ai pensé écrire un roman
mettant en scène
un tirailleur sénégalais,
en fait, dans le fond, peut-être
j'essayais de combler ce silence.
Et je me suis demandé depuis
s'il avait rencontré des tirailleurs
sénégalais, c'est possible.
Mais comme j'ai
deux sensibilités culturelles,
un pont s'est fait
entre cet homme-là
et ce tirailleur sénégalais
de fiction que j'ai inventé.
-Il faut le dire, c'est un livre
absolument terrible, tragique,
un des deux tirailleurs sénégalais
dont vous parlez défouraille,
comme on dirait aujourd'hui.
Comme quoi,
quand on parle de l'Afrique,
souvent, on a l'impression
que ça ne peut être que tragique.
Vous avez fait un autre livre,
vous en avez fait plusieurs,
mais un autre
récemment, qui a beaucoup de succès,
"La porte du voyage sans retour"
et là,
on plonge dans une autre histoire
tragique aussi,
l'histoire de l'île de Gorée,
en face de Dakar,
et d'où partaient des bateaux
remplis d'esclaves
qui prenaient le chemin
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique.
-Alors,
c'est tragique peut-être en effet,
parce que je situe mes romans
pour l'instant
dans une période coloniale.
C'est-à-dire que la colonisation
est toujours violente
et elle violente les peuples,
mais elle violente aussi
les individus
qui s'inscrivent
dans une histoire tragique,
une histoire
personnelle tragique,
une grande histoire
avec un grand "H",
qui les opprime.
Mais donc ça peut changer.
Pour l'instant,
c'est ce qui m'intéresse.
C'est de finalement placer
des personnages
dans un contexte
historique difficile
et essayer, par la force
de l'écriture ou de la fiction,
de comprendre comment ils ont pu
échapper à des contradictions
ou au contraire tomber
dans des contradictions
dans une vie qui n'était pas simple.
-Si vous me permettez, la tragédie
continue quand on voit le drame
que vivent tous exilés
qui prennent la route de l'Europe
ou des Etats-Unis
avec des moyens de fortune,
qui meurent dans la Méditerranée
puis dans la Manche
quand ils vont vers l'Angleterre.
Ca continue, ce drame
finalement de l'exil.
-Oui, oui. C'est un drame universel.
-Ca pourrait vous inspirer ?
-Ca a inspiré
beaucoup de romans déjà
et le sujet est peut-être
tellement grave
et tellement douloureux
qu'il est très difficile,
en tout cas pour moi,
de travailler sur ces sujets-là
sans qu'il y ait une distance.
Pour "Frère d'âme" autant que pour
"La porte du voyage sans retour",
j'ai l'histoire justement
qui fait distance.
C'est-à-dire qui me permet
finalement
de me retourner et de réfléchir
au sens propre du terme.
Tandis que l'actualité brûlante,
elle est extrêmement douloureuse,
elle est très proche
et elle ne me laisse pas le temps
d'y revenir
pour en tirer quelque chose
qui ne serait pas
de l'ordre du témoignage,
mais de la création littéraire
aussi, de la fiction.
Quand vous lisez les témoignages
de ces gens qui partent
et qui traversent la Méditerranée,
qui arrivent à la traverser,
ce sont des témoignages
mais qui dépassent l'imagination.
Là, vraiment, la réalité dépasse
la fiction dans l'horreur.
Et donc je n'ai rien
à ajouter à cela,
si ce n'est déplorer dans le fond
cette nouvelle souffrance,
cette souffrance infinie.
-Aujourd'hui, l'Afrique est peuplée
d'environ 1,2 ou 1,3 milliard
d'habitants,
on dit que, d'ici à 25 ans,
il y en aura 2 milliards.
Est-ce que les Africains
sont condamnés à l'exil ?
-Non.
-Vous êtes pas pessimiste
à ce point-là ?
-Alors, il faut peut-être aller
au-delà de cette antithèse
entre l'optimisme et le pessimisme.
C'est-à-dire qu'on ne peut pas
prévoir de quoi
l'avenir sera fait.
On peut avoir des évolutions
absolument inimaginables.
Et donc, moi, je me garderai bien
de faire de la prospective.
Je sais que l'Afrique est
tellement diverse,
il y a tellement
de situations différentes,
il y a aussi une force
qui appartient à l'Afrique,
c'est que,
comme vous venez de le dire,
elle a une jeunesse qui explose,
qui est extrêmement dynamique.
Donc je ne peux pas dire
si je suis optimiste ou pessimiste.
Je peux simplement dire
qu'il faut avoir l'espoir
que les choses s'arrangent.
-Vous partagez pas cette phrase
que je trouve extraordinaire
d'Alain Mabanckou, qui dit que
le danger pour l'écrivain noir est
de s'enfermer dans sa noirceur ?
Vous la connaissez, bien sûr.
-Oui, alors,
c'est peut-être un danger,
mais c'est-à-dire que,
pour ressentir ou avoir
le sentiment qu'il y a danger,
il faut affronter ce danger
ou le rencontrer.
J'ai pas l'impression de devoir
éviter des écueils dans le fond.
Je me sens très tranquille
par rapport à l'écriture,
très tranquille
par rapport aux choix
que je pourrais faire.
Je suis pas dans une démarche
où je serais aliéné par mes sujets.
-Mabanckou dit aussi,
il faut en finir
avec les sanglots de l'homme noir,
comme Bruckner disait
les sanglots de l'homme blanc.
Vous êtes d'accord avec ça,
cette espèce de plainte ?
-Dans mes romans en tout cas
mes personnages ne se plaignent pas.
Ils vivent leur vie fictive en fait.
Et ce qui moi
m'intéresse en tout cas dans
ma façon d'aborder la littérature,
c'est dans le fond de donner
des éléments au lecteur
pour qu'il se fasse
à partir de sa propre imagination
une idée du monde
dans lequel je veux le plonger.
-C'est ça.
-J'ai pas de message particulier.
-Vous n'êtes pas un romancier
engagé, vous n'avez pas
de message à faire passer ?
-Non. Si ce n'est pour déplorer
comme beaucoup d'autres,
comme on le disait tout à l'heure,
par exemple le drame
que vivent ces migrants
qui traversent
la Méditerranée centrale
et au sujet desquels on m'a
demandé de faire un article dans
le New York Times ou dans Le Monde.
Là, je me suis senti obligé
d'une certaine façon de témoigner
de ce que
cette situation était horrible.
Mais la littérature pour moi,
elle a plusieurs façons peut-être
d'aborder des thématiques
universelles,
pas nécessairement africaines
d'ailleurs,
qui peuvent toucher
le lecteur, l'émouvoir,
sans qu'il soit dit qu'il faille
faire du didactisme
et un enseignement qui serait
asséné comme cela au lecteur.
Voltaire dit dans son dictionnaire
philosophique que, selon lui,
les livres les plus utiles sont ceux
dont les lecteurs font
eux-mêmes la moitié.
-C'est très joli, ça.
Et donc vous avez beaucoup
de distance par rapport au wokisme,
à la cancel culture, c'est pas
du tout votre sujet ?
Vous condamnez ça, d'ailleurs,
cette remise en question
de l'histoire ?
-Alors, moi, je condamne
ce que je connais.
C'est-à-dire
que je ne sais pas exactement
ce qu'est le wokisme.
J'entends de-ci de-là
qu'il y a beaucoup
de définitions qui sont données.
Ce que je trouve quand même
appréciable peut-être
dans ce qu'on appelle le wokisme,
mais qui peut-être s'appelait
autrement avant,
c'est cette capacité
qu'on peut s'offrir à soi-même
de réfléchir sur ce qui est présenté
comme étant dogmatique,
c'est-à-dire une représentation
de l'histoire du monde,
qui peut en effet
être construite en Europe
et peut-être
déconstruite ailleurs.
Il y a un penseur qui est vraiment
très important en France,
Michel Foucault,
qui a construit des outils d'analyse
de certaines périodes,
de l'histoire des idées
et notamment le régime
de véridiction.
Il explique que
chaque période historique en Europe
se construit
un régime de pensée
dans lequel on admet
à un moment donné
que telle chose est vraie
et que telle chose est fausse.
J'aime beaucoup cette façon
d'aborder les moments de l'histoire.
Il est possible qu'en ce moment,
on change de régime de véridiction
par rapport à des choses
qu'on ne pensait pas...
-Vous appelez ça véridiction ?
-Voilà, véridiction.
Un régime de véridiction, oui.
-Alors, vous êtes métis,
puisque votre mère est française,
votre père est sénégalais.
Quelque part
vous avez écrit que le métissage,
c'est une conciliation.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez
dire par là ?
-En tout cas, moi,
je l'ai vécu comme ça
et mon frère et ma soeur
aussi, je pense.
On est dans une famille
où on a la chance
de recevoir l'affection
autant des parents de ma mère
que ceux de mon père.
C'est une chance. C'est pas
applicable ou généralisable,
mais c'est
dans mon histoire personnelle.
-Ce sont deux cultures
qui se sont rencontrées,
qui ont vécu en osmose ?
-En osmose, c'est-à-dire
où il n'y a pas eu d'antagonisme.
-Ce qui est rare, non ?
-Je n'en sais rien,
je ne parle que de mon expérience
personnelle. C'est pour ça
que je dis qu'il y a conciliation,
c'est pour éviter de dire
que le métissage nécessairement
peut surgir
d'un antagonisme.
Il n'y a pas eu d'antagonisme.
J'ai reçu de l'affection
au Sénégal et en France.
C'est un cas personnel.
-Vous avez une très belle dédicace
d'ailleurs dans "Frère d'âme",
vous dites : "A mes parents,
passeurs de vie
"métisse."
C'est magnifique comme hommage.
-Oui. Je trouve qu'on a eu
un univers
dans lequel on a finalement
fait se rencontrer
deux cultures différentes
avec beaucoup d'aménité,
beaucoup d'ouverture d'esprit.
En fait, en effet,
ils nous ont appris nos parents,
autant mon père que ma mère,
à nous ouvrir à d'autres réalités.
Et ça, je trouve
que c'est un très grand
cadeau qu'ils nous ont fait.
-Est-ce pour ça que vous enseignez
le 18e siècle
à l'université de Pau ?
Le 18e siècle,
c'est le siècle de l'universel.
-Oui.
-Ca peut s'expliquer aussi
par ce métissage ?
-Euh, peut-être. Peut-être.
Moi, ce que j'aime dans Voltaire,
c'est son côté insolent.
Et j'ai cité Voltaire,
mais il n'y a pas que Voltaire.
La littérature du 18e siècle,
c'est une littérature
qu'il faut replacer
dans un contexte précis,
où, en effet, il y avait
une oppression contre laquelle
les philosophes ont lutté
et une oppression
qui a conduit
à l'expression de grandes idées
autour des droits de l'homme.
Et donc, on leur doit beaucoup.
Mais c'est le siècle aussi,
le 18e siècle,
du pic de l'esclavage
transatlantique.
-Le commerce
triangulaire,
tout ce que dénonçait Montesquieu,
l'abbé Raynal, Diderot.
-Exactement.
Celui, je pense, qui le dénonçait
le plus clairement, c'était Diderot,
mais bon, ceci dit,
ce qui m'a plu dans ce siècle,
c'est son côté contestataire,
cette remise en cause
des idées reçues.
Et puis ce qui me plaît aussi
dans la littérature du 18e siècle,
c'est que c'est une littérature
qui a su s'adapter
à ce que nous ne connaissons
peut-être pas aujourd'hui encore
ou qui apparaît sous d'autres
formes, à la censure.
C'est une littérature
qui tire aussi sa grandeur
des stratégies
de contournement de la censure
qu'elle a opéré.
-Je voudrais vous soumettre
une phrase de Senghor
qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre :
"L'émotion est nègre
et la raison est hellène."
Est grecque,
puisqu'il était passionné
de langues anciennes.
-Oui.
Oui, oui. Alors, c'est une phrase
qui a suscité évidemment
beaucoup de réactions,
parce qu'elle était considérée,
et, on peut le dire,
d'une certaine manière
à juste titre,
comme étant un peu
une caricature de la négritude
par rapport à l'hellénité
ou le monde gréco-romain.
Moi, je replace cette phrase
dans un contexte
à la fois politique et littéraire.
Senghor écrit cela u moment
du mouvement de la négritude.
Il essaie de trouver ce qui fait
justement cette négritude
et donc il travaille,
il réfléchit
sur la façon d'exprimer
cette idée-là.
Mais c'est une phrase qui a suscité
beaucoup de réactions.
-Oui.
-J'ai entendu Souleymane
Bachir Diane ici même expliquer,
et je rejoins son point de vue,
qu'il faut replacer cette phrase
dans la connaissance
qu'avait Senghor du philosophe...
-De Bergson ?
-De Bergson, voilà.
Qu'il fallait la lire,
cette phrase, de cette façon-là.
Mais d'une manière générale,
tous les marxistes-léninistes
de ces années-là, africains,
ont considéré que c'était
une phrase qui était
absolument détestable
et que c'était la manifestation
de l'esprit bourgeois de Senghor.
La négritude, Kwame Nkrumah
l'a dit très clairement,
le premier président du Ghana,
qui était marxiste-léniniste,
a rejeté absolument cette phrase-là.
-David Diop,
avez-vous une musique africaine
que vous préférez ?
Qui est votre élue du coeur ?
-Oui, j'aime bien la musique
sénégalaise dans l'ensemble.
Le mbalax.
-Oui.
-Et puis j'aime bien
les morceaux anciens
que j'entendais pendant ma jeunesse,
notamment celui-là
de l'Orchestra Baobab,
"Dée Moo Woor", ce qui veut dire,
la mort est certaine,
c'est pas très gai.
-C'est pas très gai.
-Mais elle me fait penser
à des moments
à la fois tristes et heureux.
C'est une définition même
de la nostalgie.
-Vous êtes nostalgique ?
-Oui, très.
-Et vous êtes nostalgique
de vos années sénégalaises
quand vous étiez petit à l'école ?
-Voilà, c'est ça, c'est-à-dire
à la fois nostalgique d'une époque
qui serait absolument
révolue, quand je pense
à mes parents, je les vois jeunes
en entendant cette musique.
-D'accord.
-Mais c'est pas
une nostalgie irrémédiable,
qui me plongerait dans une sorte
de désespoir aujourd'hui.
-Vous êtes optimiste
pour le Sénégal et l'Afrique ?
-Oui.
-Merci, David Diop.
-Je vous en prie.
"Dée Moo Woor",
Orchestra Baobab
...
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA